can you tell us the time in your life
when you were kicked out of your comfort
zone I think you had talked about them
before and how how do we deal with being
kicked out of our comfort zone and how
do we kind of go with it is it back to
trust again it's what the meeting but
this keep getting kicked out of our
comfort zone as I've had this happen so
many times not just in the process of
being a corporate financial person but I
have been kicked out of my comfort zone
through the stone process more than any
other time in my life because I used to
work in a structure in an organization
and I knew what my job was with this
whole filmmaking thing as a producer I
had to wear all the hats the financing
the technical the directing the
directors and the Purdue any editors and
so getting out of the comfort zone it
gets to a key point in the film is
you've got to allow yourself to feel the
fear and to feel the anger and feeling
anxiety and that's where the heart comes
in because in my head I could talk to
myself until I was blue in the face and
say I'm you know I'm going to get this
I've try to convince myself that I'm
gonna rise to the occasion but it was
when I went into the feelings and the
deep fear that i'm going to fail or i'm
going to be seen as a fake or this is
going to flop or i am going to look like
an idiot because i didn't know any of
this stuff but then I kept going into
the feeling that this is this is the
fear that's inside and this is here for
a reason not because there's something
wrong with me but this is all that old
programming and so in order to move out
of that comfort zone I had to go into
the feelings that mess that's inside
that chaos and really dig deep and say I
let myself feel it and then I move the
energy and some in some way that
integrates it and then from there it
frees up a whole new way of being and
it's it was very profound and it and it
really works as we talk in the film it
really works to take take things on in
this way
you